the cdc
is encouraging your kids to visit
groomer chat websites
and hide it from you
from their parents i'm not joking it
sounds like a sensational headline it's
really not the center for disease
control is promoting two young people an
online chat space that discusses sex
polyamorous relationships sex change
operations activism
and the occult
a little bit of a sidebar but isn't it
weird how whenever you go far enough
down
the leftist especially the sexual
revolution leftist activism you end up
at overt satanism
isn't that weird even drag queen story
hour why do the drag queens dress up
like demons
frequently
why do why does the pro-abortion
activism often take on
explicitly satanic imagery
why does why do
why does leftist activism take on the
language of witchcraft or spells or the
occult why does that happen
almost as though there's a spiritual
reality to all of this and certainly at
a practical level we have to ask why is
the cdc promoting creepy weird sex stuff
and the occult to little kids on
websites the website is called q chat
that that have buttons that you can make
it that make it much easier for the
children to hide the websites for the
parents if the parents walk by
the chat hosts conversations on topics
such as drag culture 101 sex and
relationships having multiple genders by
pan youth a gender affirmation surgeries
hormone therapy self-discovery in
astrology and queering tarot tarot
the weird occult cards
not not tarot seems bad enough but then
they're going to queer tarot as well
why why that one
this reminds us that there is no
neutrality here the government is going
to be pushing some set of values or
another and uh either they're going to
be pushing
the devil's values like this tarot and
queering the occult and chop off your
genitals five-year-olds or they're going
to be pushing good true
virtuous values your pick i think when
the conservatives need to stop throwing
our hands in the air and pretending this
is all neutral and enforce our vision of
the good all political life involves
promoting some vision of the good and
discouraging some vision of the bad and
so we ought to do the correct one not
this creepy one
but it is a reminder too
i've mentioned this a few times in
recent weeks it's the iq bell curve meme
really dumb people who are drooling who
just duh they don't know anything about
politics they say i think the bad stuff
is because of the devil and the good
stuff you know good stuff is about god
right and then the people in the middle
it's like well actually you know those
are all just metaphors and what it's
really about is um the
marxism and post-modernism and this ism
and that ism and it's a really just the
metaphor of your inner blah blah blah
and then you get to the people who are
really smart like the thomas aquinas end
of the iq spectrum and they say no it's
about god
and the rejection of god in that is
personified in the devil who is a real
person by the way who you can worship
but you shouldn't worship that's what
it's really about that's why it always
comes down to this this is why the
weirdos on tick-tock who are trying to
trans your kids is why they always look
like demons and the more they get into
it the more they look like demons and
they wear they have explicit satanic
imagery on there
maybe instead of dismissing all of that
and saying oh we're so we know none of
that exists how about we look at all of
human history in all cultures and say
how come they all have a conception of
god and a conception of the devil
isn't that kind of weird maybe there's
some wisdom in that that we should pay
attention to right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast do this right now
you are getting pinched we are all
getting pinched at the gas tank when we
go buy groceries why are we getting
pinched because of all the terrible
policies that are causing everything to
skyrocket in price
except for your cell phone bill if you
switch to pure talk you're probably
spending what 80 90 a month for your
cell phone plan what if i told you you
could get the exact same extremely high
quality service talk texts plenty of
data for 30 bucks a month i am a pure
talk customer the 5g coverage is great
it's a veteran-owned company customer
service is right here in the u.s i know
it's always scary to switch your cell
phone you think it's going to be a
hassle you never want to do it it's so
simple at puretalk and you will save so
much money they make it really easy
there's a no risk money-back guarantee
go to puretalk.com select a plan enter
promo code knowles podcast to save 50
off your first month by the way pure
talk sponsors the voice mailbag as
though you didn't already have reason
enough they are bringing you the
wonderful voice mail bag so head on over
you can switch over to pure talk in less
than 10 minutes promo code knowles
podcast know
w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com
hey michael my name's chris i'm 17 and
i'm a resident of central florida after
fleeing ontario canada last november
i'm a big fan of the daily wire and i've
heard almost all of the main
personalities share their opposition to
red flag laws which i am also opposed to
my only confusion is with the proposed
alternatives i've heard that the mass
shooters that seemed unstable before
committing the shootings should have
been institutionalized which i'm not
opposed to but my issue comes up with
the fact that if we're able to lock
people up in mental facilities against
their will for seeming dangerous
couldn't the government use this
institutionalization as a tactic in the
same way they might use red flag laws
thanks again big fan really good
question
the answer is yes but not exactly in the
same way and this is why a lot of people
who oppose things like red flag laws
and oppose things like most gun control
measures also support increasing the
ease with which people can be
institutionalized because you've just
got to make the threshold very very high
the problem with red flag laws is the
threshold for depriving people of their
constitutional and civil rights is very
very low the way democrats talk about
red flag was the red flag is you
listening to this show is a red flag
voting for donald trump is a red flag
having an american flag outside of your
home is a red flag it's the red white
and blue flag and they're going to take
away your guns
so that threshold is so low and it's so
vague
to
involuntarily commit someone to an
insane asylum the threshold has to be at
least relatively high now it's so high
that it's virtually impossible i think
we should lower that threshold a little
bit but it's still going to be very very
high and it forces you to grapple with
the reality of what it means to deprive
someone of their second amendment rights
when you deprive someone of their second
amendment rights which is a a basic
right a constitutional right a civil
right and the right to self-defense is a
natural right you are saying i must
deprive you you of all of your rights
because you are not able to exercise
them at all you are not able to live
your life as a normal human being so
you're you're really making that clear
and for some people that's true people
who are insane people who are not able
to take care of themselves sure okay
that we already have laws in the books
for this right relatives can exercise
power of attorney if an if a loved one
say uh becomes senile or
otherwise incapacitated so we already
have ways to do this
but it's a way of saying okay you want
to take away my rights well then take
away my rights to really take away my
rights
because
if not if you're not willing to do that
if you're not willing to lock me up in a
straight jacket then let me have my guns
let me have my right to self-defense
don't don't pull a little bait and
switch here well
you're not crazy enough that we're going
to take care of you or really change
your lifestyle at all but you are so
crazy that we we need to deprive you of
your really really basic rights that's
that's the game that the libs are trying
to play right now we want to clarify
the mistakes i'm really glad you like
that clip i need a favor i'm very close
to 1 million subscribers and if i get a
million subscribers i will feel like a
very very cool guy so i need you if you
have not already subscribed click that
bell just subscribe ring it get the
notifications if you have already
subscribed just copy the link to this
channel and send it to all of your
friends every single one of them tell
them to subscribe we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]